we're ready to die for you they shout
the Army is unacceptable
Imran Khan's supporters enraged and
unrelenting
this is what we're constantly seeing
pitch rattles between protesters and the
police with no resolution in sight they
are demanding change they want the shape
of this country
to be completely different
[Applause]
[Music]
they feel Under Siege I'm a doctor I've
been in the protest since yesterday and
all security personnels all agencies
they are firing State fires on the
people the authorities they're not
taking care of the people you can see
what what's going on right now what we
want we just want to release Imran Khan
nothing else foreign
dragged from a courtroom by Pakistan's
paramilitary Imran Khan was back in
another today a judge ruling he could be
held for eight days on corruption
charges which he denies his team framing
it as political persecution more
career
number one
Imran Khan
um
[Music]
wherever you're standing this looks like
a very vulnerable moment
but the government insists the legal
process must play out
while the military vowed to take action
against anyone pushing Pakistan towards
Civil War
dictatorships and coups are part of
Pakistan's history and so are protests
the question is whether Imran Khan's
arrest will play into his hands or will
create the kind of violence that only
delays his Central goal for an early
election
what happens in the next few days could
help decide that right now though the
ground looks too unstable to judge
Sky News Islamabad Pakistan